were these actors not bold enough to go
where no one has gone before or were
there other factors behind their refusal
of Star Trek roles as the human Vulcan
first officer of the Enterprise and an
instant favorite among the fan base
Leonard Nimoy Spock is one of the most
iconic characters on television while it
may be hard to imagine anyone but Nimoy
playing Spock on Star Trek the Original
Series the actor was reportedly not
series Creator Gene roddenberry's first
pick for the part instead Roddenberry
favorite comedic actor George Lindsay
best known for playing the Goofy Goober
pile on The Andy Griffith Show and its
sequel series Mayberry RFD
in a short television bumper for TV Land
Nimoy attests that Lindsay was
roddenberry's first choice for the role
that made him a household name this
claim is corroborated by prolific actor
Ernest Borgnine in his Memoir Ernie
recalling that his friend Lindsay turned
the part of Spock down without
elaborating on the rationale behind the
refusal Lindsay would continue to play
largely comedic roles on film and
television for the remainder of his
career before his death in 2012.
another actor reportedly offered the
role of Spock ahead of Nimoy was Academy
Award winner Martin Landau who had
appeared in high-profile supporting
roles in films including North by
Northwest
in a 1986 interview with starlog
magazine Landau confirmed he was
approached to take the role of the
Vulcan science officer but claimed he
wasn't interested in playing an
emotionless character unfavorably
comparing Spock's stoic nature to a
glorified newscaster instead he took on
a very different television role
starring as Master of Disguise role in
hand in the original Mission Impossible
TV series
in a separate interview for where no man
has gone before a history in pictures
ronberry confirmed Landau was being
considered for the role saying the actor
was a possibility elaborating on the
potential casting Ron Berry attributed
landau's busy schedule with other
projects at the time as the primary
cause behind his turning down the role
in a coincidental twist Nimoy replaced
Landau on mission impossible as the
magician Paris after Landau left the
Series in 1969 several months after the
cancellation of Star Trek
fascinating while developing Star Trek 4
the Voyage Home director and co-writer
Leonard Nimoy learned that popular
comedian and actor Eddie Murphy was
apparently a big fan of the franchise
in a retrospective Interview With The
Hollywood Reporter co-writer Steve
meerson recalled that an early script
contain a part specifically written for
Murphy which would have had the comic
Powerhouse interact with the Enterprise
crew Murphy was set to play an
astrophysicist at Berkeley while the
original series crew visited
California's Bay Area in 1986 to save
their timeline by rescuing humpback
whales no I want to go I want to beam up
and it's going to be on the ship you
know so I didn't do it yeah no you have
to be on the Enterprise negotiations
with Murphy reportedly broke down before
filming began however leading the
comedian slash actor to drop out from
the project his planned astrophysicist
character was cut from the story
entirely and replaced with marine
biologist Dr Jillian Taylor played by
Catherine Hicks this provided Kirk with
a romantic foil
acclaimed actor Edward James almost had
two close opportunities to be cast in
Major Star Trek roles though he
ultimately has yet to appear in any
iteration of the franchise director
Leonard Nimoy approached almost to play
the villainous Commander Krug in Star
Trek 3 The Search for Spock but was
overruled by the producers according to
William Shatner's Memoir Star Trek movie
memories however almost a second brush
with Star Trek saw him turn down an even
bigger opportunity with the long-running
Sci-Fi franchise that would have made
him an esteemed Starfleet captain
according to trekmovie.com he was
offered to Star as Picard in Star Trek
the Next Generation reportedly turning
down the part because of its high level
of commitment and his own schedule at
the time in an interview with the AV
club almost explained that his decision
to return to sci-fi in Battlestar
Galactica over his previous Star Trek
offer was driven by the quality of
Storytelling present in the series's
writing
the late celebrated actor yaphet Koto
has starred in a number of fan favorite
projects in film and television
including a part as Nostromo technician
Dennis Parker in the classic science
fiction horror film Alien kodo nearly
took on an even more iconic sci-fi role
as Captain Jean-Luc Picard the lead
character in Star Trek the Next
Generation
according to a BBC interview with
producer Robert Justman series Creator
Gene Roddenberry was initially not
enthused by Patrick Stewart's audition
for the part and looked to other actors
to take on the role among the actors who
read for the character was kodo who
turned down the part over his concerns
about shifting to television following a
prolific film career in an interview
with the big issue Coda reflected on
this decision with regret referring to
his rejection of the chance to play
Picard as a wrong decision ironically he
would transition to a television career
years later starring as Baltimore police
detective Al gordello across the entire
run of the acclaimed crime series
homicide life on the street
the 1989 film Star Trek 5 the final
frontier introduces Spock's long-lost
older brother saibach who commandeers
the Enterprise to find God at the center
of the Galaxy
played by Lawrence luckenbill cybak is a
Vulcan in touch with and open about his
emotions the character was written for
Sean Connery fresh off of his Academy
award-winning performance in The
Untouchables but the Scottish actor
turned down the part according to
trekmovie.com Connery rejected the role
due to his commitments to appear in
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
despite Connery's absence in the final
frontier the film's holy Planet Shakari
was named after him as a subtle nod to
the intended casting years later it was
revealed that a different actor very
familiar to trekkies apparently vied for
the cybach role unsuccessfully in an
interview with star trek.com luckenbill
claims that Nimoy lobbied to play cybak
for a dual role in Star Trek 5 but was
rejected because the siblings weren't
twins
me I find that selection highly
a lot is Star Trek the Next Generation
steadily grew in popularity across its
seven season run the writers wanted to
find a way to include actor and comedian
Robin Williams in a guest appearance
Williams was a self-professed fan of
Star Trek even going so far as to
reference the franchise directly in his
hit sci-fi sitcom Mork and Mindy the
writers created a part specifically for
Williams in the season 5 episode a
matter of time as burlingov Rasmussen a
time-traveling con man scheming to steal
Starfleet technology for himself
unfortunately scheduling conflicted with
the 1991 Steven Spielberg film hook
which prevented him from appearing on
the Next Generation Rasmussen was
instead played by actor Matt fruer best
known for his 80s cult classic character
Max Headroom
Kim Cattrall appeared in Star Trek 6 the
Undiscovered Country as Volaris Spock's
young Vulcan Protege on the Enterprise
and the starship's new Helmsman after
Sulu was given his own command though
Volaris is eventually revealed to be a
traitor and part of the conspiracy to
assassinate Klingon Chancellor gowron
Katrell nearly had a continuing future
with the wider Star Trek franchise on
television
however rather than reprising her role
as the duplicitous Vulcan valeris
catrell was offered the part of bajoran
security officer Kira Norris in Star
Trek Deep Space Nine in a leaked casting
memo for Deep Space Nine from 1992
catral is among the names appearing near
the top of the list to play the
no-nonsense bajoran freedom fighter she
is cited in the memo as passing on the
role though no further explanation
behind her decision is included in the
document Cottrell would find
considerable success Elsewhere on
television starring as the vivacious
businesswoman and socialite Samantha
Jones a role she also nearly turned down
in the acclaimed HBO series Sex in the
City there are plenty of other names on
the leaked casting memo for Kira in Deep
Space Nine all of whom are listed as a
pass or unavailable next to Cattrall the
most notable actor on the list is Rita
Wilson prolific television and film
actor and wife of lifelong Star Trek fan
Tom Hanks however like Cattrall and the
other actors under consideration Wilson
turned down the role with the memo
sighting she wasn't interested in
working in television at the time
interestingly Nana Visitor who
ultimately was cast as Kira for Deep
Space Nine and Star Trek lower decks is
not among the names listed on the memo
visitors agent cautioned her against
taking the role feeling it would be
detrimental to her career but as variety
explains she was impressed by the
character and accepted Wilson has gone
on to play numerous supporting roles in
film and television notably as recurring
characters on The Good Wife and girls
while Kate Mulgrew may be best known for
bringing Catherine Janeway to life in
the television show Star Trek Voyager
and Star Trek Prodigy she was not the
first actor cast in the role Academy
award-nominated actor Genevieve Boucher
was initially cast as the Voyager
commanding officer Captain Nicole
Janeway maintaining the role as
principal photography began in 1994.
however as the New York Times reports
two days into filming Bujo decided to
quit the series over concerns regarding
the show's demanding work schedule she's
keeping me awake for four days straight
with the constant pain of your devices
drilling into my skull Mulgrew who was
among the actors that initially read for
the role of Janeway during the casting
process was called back in the wake of
bourjo's sudden departure and accepted
the lead part with the character renamed
Catherine Janeway to reflect the shift
in actors Mulgrew quickly brought the
memorable Captain to life as filming
resumed for her part boujo returned to
focus primarily on film work with the
occasional TV movie she never starred as
the lead in a television series across
her distinguished career
audiences were treated to a bold
reinvention of the Star Trek franchise
in 2009 with filmmaker JJ Abrams humming
a reboot movie that recast the classic
characters from the original series
among the iconic crew reimagined for the
film was Spock played by Zachary Quinto
across the trilogy as a Vulcan with a
fiery temper under histoic exterior
however Quinto was not the only actor in
consideration for the role Academy Award
winner Adrian Brody was approached by
Abrams to potentially portray the
Enterprise's logical first officer
in an interview with MTV Brody confirmed
he spoke with Abrams about playing Spock
in the 2009 Star Trek even sharing the
news of his potential casting with his
parents though he expressed regret about
not taking the part he is not fully
divulged specifics as to why he didn't
appear as the iconic science officer
with the new younger cast of the
original series era front and center in
the 2009 Star Trek one of the actors
widely rumored to be considered to play
James Kirk was Matt Damon Damon himself
publicly dismissed the casting as
Internet rumors observing that the
reboot was looking for a younger actor
for the role however months after the
movie was released it was revealed that
Damon was being considered for a
different character Abrams confirmed
that he did approach Damon for a role in
the film later clarifying in an
interview with MTV that he spoke to him
about playing James Kirk's father George
Abrams revealed that Damon graciously
turned down the role so Australian actor
Chris Hemsworth played the ill-fated
George Kirk instead
2013 Star Trek Into Darkness is a
strange sequel offering a loose Retreat
of Star Trek 2 the Wrath of Khan within
the storytelling sensibilities of the
reboot timeline that began in 2009 the
film pits the Enterprise crew against
the Genetically Enhanced superhuman Khan
noonian Singh the classic villainous
role originated by Ricardo Montalban
Academy Award winner Benicio del Toro
entered negotiations to play the reboot
timeline's iteration of Khan during a
time when the identity of the movie's
antagonist remained unconfirmed in the
face of mounting speculation according
to vulture Del Toro decided to drop out
of Into Darkness after salary
negotiations broke down approximately
one month before filming was scheduled
to begin instead English actor Benedict
Cumberbatch played Khan in the final
film Into Darkness endured criticism for
casting a Caucasian actress Khan while
director J.J Abrams admitted attempting
to keep Khan's true identity a secret
was a mistake Del Toro would go on to
play two very different sci-fi roles in
Star Wars The Last Jedi and Guardians of
the Galaxy
foreign